[Music]
actors often have to make difficult
decisions especially when they are faced
with the choice of which role to take on
next subsequently it's not uncommon that
the chosen path was the right one and
that certain roles are forever
associated with a specific person
however cast as we know them were not
always the ones the directors wanted
and often the originally planned actors
are still upset about the missed
opportunity
here is a compilation of stars who were
actually not the first choice for their
role
keanu reeves is one of the most popular
actors in hollywood today with his down
to earth manner he has been charming
fans for years
the 56 year old made his film debut back
in 1985 in the film letting go
however his big breakthrough definitely
came with the role of neo in the science
fiction trilogy
the matrix what many people don't know
is that originally will smith was
supposed to get the role of the chosen
one instead of him
however he declined the role preferring
to take on the role of us army captain
james west and the steampunk western
wild wild west
a decision he surely regrets today while
wild wild west failed hard with the
critics
matrix is already going into its fourth
round in 2022
needless to say kian reeves will be back
in the lead role
with box office earnings of almost 2.2
billion euros and 11 oscars titanic is
still one of the most successful movies
of all time
the film held the then 23 year old
leonardo dicaprio to his incomparable
hollywood career
not only because of the film's success
but also thanks to his outstanding
acting performance
an honor that originally belonged to
someone else the role was intended for
none other than tom cruise
ultimately dicaprio got the role much to
the delight of millions of yearning
teenagers
however not only was the role of jack
dawson supposed to have been cast
differently
but rose was also meant to have a
completely different face
director james cameron's first choice
was actually gwyneth paltrow who wasn't
that famous at the time but she turned
down the role actress kate winslet thus
got the chance and became a world star
in no time
a little consolation for paltrow she
didn't have to wait much longer for her
international success
receiving the oscar for best actress in
a leading role in 1999 for her role as
viola de lesseps and the film
shakespeare in love harrison ford has
played the role of indiana jones a total
of four times
and there are constantly new rumors
about a fifth part but creators steven
spielberg and george lucas didn't intend
to have ford in their movie right from
the start the desired candidate for the
popular archaeologist was supposed to be
tom
selleck but he had already signed his
contract for the cult tv series magnum
pi at the time
the shooting of the series was later
postponed by six months so select was
resentful about the missed opportunity
as he admitted later on
this is how harrison ford get the role
of the treasure hunter and since then
it's hard to imagine the hollywood world
without him
a few years earlier bird reynolds had a
symbol of fate to that of tom selleck
and here too
the big winner was harrison ford
reynolds was first offered the role of
han solo and star wars a new hope
he turned it down however and so
director george lucas had to start
looking for a new smuggler that's how he
discovered harrison ford who was
completely unknown back then and who
mainly made his living as a carpenter
reynolds later spoke of the biggest
mistake of his acting career he didn't
blame himself however but said his agent
had advised him against the role a
little fun fact
before the role of han solo he turned
down another big role namely that of the
charming secret agent james bond which
was taken by
none other than sean connery
until the fourth part will smith was
probably the most well-known face of
this science fiction series man in black
together with dummy lee jones he went on
the hunt for aliens as agent jay
yet in the first part released in 1997
he was not intended for this role at
all director barry sunfield actually
planned to cast david schwimmer who was
already known for his famous tv series
friends
schwimmer though had to turn down the
role because he was already directing
the movie
since you've been gone in which he also
played the lead and so the ambitious
young will smith became agent j do you
think the character would have gotten
the same hive with schwimmer in the role
robert downey jr had his big
breakthrough with iron man and was
finally able to put his past behind him
which had been plagued by drug scandals
as well as
other incidents he grew to become a
world star and is now a friend and
mentor to young acting colleagues like
tom holland
not only on screen but things could have
turned out very differently for him
the role of this steely superhero was
also offered to other actors
including tom cruise when he was asked
about this in a later interview he
responded that he loved robert downey jr
and couldn't imagine
anyone else in the role an appraisal
that proves greatness and is certainly
shared by
many including us the lord of the rings
has shaped many acting careers
for instance actor elijah wood is always
associated with frodo
wiggle mortensen with aragorn and sean
astin with the character of samwise
gumji
it is different regarding the role of
gandalf since actor ian mckellen had
already been a hollywood star for
years however it is controversial that
it was actually not mcallen but james
bond star sean connery who was intended
for the role of the great wizard
the rumors even go so far as to claim
that the producers were so eager to hire
connery that they promised him 15
of the revenues plus 10 million us
dollars for each movie
if he were to sign the contract in an
interview however connery said that he
didn't understand anything
later he literally said i never
understood it i read the book i read the
script i saw the movie i
still don't understand it pretty
upsetting for him
since he led a combined total of about
450
million us dollars slipped through his
fingers which could have made him the
highest paid actor of
all time with six oscars the film
musical la la land was the big winner in
2017 and leading actress emma stone was
able to celebrate the highlight of her
career by winning
an oscar as is now known she and fellow
actor ryan gosling were hardly the first
choice candidates when it came to
casting the lead roles
as director damian schezel later
revealed in an interview the role of mia
dolan was actually intended for harry
potter star emma watson
she did seem to have great interest in
the role but when casting for the movie
dragged on for six years
she eventually lost her interest instead
watson opted for the role of belle in
the fairytale adaption of beauty and the
beast
for the role of sebastian wilder
chazelle had actually envisioned miles
teller with whom he had already worked
in the 2014 release drama whiplash
however his salary demands were far too
high and rumor has it that he didn't
feel like practicing the piano for weeks
on end
so the role was passed on and was
thankfully given to
ryan gosling since iron man 2 we have
been able to watch scarlett johansson in
the role of natasha romanov
aka black widow this year her character
will find its conclusion in the film of
the same name
nevertheless as has since become known
the rule was reserved for someone
completely different
namely for a quiet place actress emily
blund
she was the first to be offered the role
but she had to turn it down as she had
already committed to shooting the comedy
gulliver's travels with jack black
although the film flopped blonde still
managed to have a great hollywood
career fans haven't given up on emily
yet and hope to see her as the next sue
richard alias the invisible woman of the
fantastic four if the next reboot is
ever to be produced for scarlett
johansson it came at the perfect time
because even though the american actress
was no longer an unknown actress
the role of black widow took her to a
whole new level
with the role of jack sparrow a pardon
me of course i mean captain jack sparrow
johnny depp managed to successfully
portray a character that probably could
not be cast with
anyone else today funny when you
consider that the role of the pirate was
actually meant for someone else
namely none other than comedy star jim
carrey he was indeed favored by director
gore rubinski
in the end kerry reluctantly had to turn
it down because he had already signed on
for the role of bruce in the eponymous
film bruce
almighty although the quality of the
pirates of the caribbean movies has
certainly declined
depp was still the right choice in
retrospect don't you think
while there are some films that were a
huge success as a result of great acting
there are also productions that flopped
at the box office left us wondering
whether it would have been better with a
different lead actor
one example is the science fiction film
jupiter is sending it's dark mila kunis
is jupiter jones and channing tatum
as kane wise greatly announced the movie
is now considered as one of the major
flops of the last 10
years especially the main actor seemed
rather flat in the science fiction opera
of the matrix makers it is interesting
to note that shortly before shooting
began
natalie portman was being considered for
the role of jupiter jones and joseph
gordon-levitt was also expected to play
the leading role
however both cancelled whether the weak
leading roles are attributable to the
acting performances of kunis and tandem
or rather the script
is up to debate
another title we had hide hopes for was
the video game adaption prince of persia
the sense of time from 2010
in the film of the same name adoptive
prince dazed and played by jack
gyllenhaal
must protect the dagger that contains
this sense of time from
sheikh amar and his power hungry brother
nizam unfortunately like most game
adaptions the film did not live up to
the expectations of fans and critics
earning only 90 million dollars at the
american box office
what's interesting to know is that
gyllenhaal and his acting colleague
gemma arden who plays
princess tamina were not the desired
casts while dashing was supposed to be
played by charlie clawson tamina was
meant to be portrayed by the iranian
actress
goshiti farahani however her role in
ridley scott's body of lies got her
arrested at the airport and she wasn't
allowed to leave iran for 6 months
which is why arthelene got the role once
again though we don't want to put the
blame completely on the actors
it's always a challenge for directors to
fit such an elaborate game into a
hollywood movie and sadly they usually
make sacrifices that ruin the experience
for fans
which casting choice surprised you the
most and can you think of any roles that
would have been better cast
differently let us know in the comments
we hope you enjoyed our selection
if you don't want to miss any future
videos well you know what to do
until then take care
[Music]